hôm nay họ báo chính phủ triệu 1 thân tư bộ công thương cho biết trong tháng 3, các thương nhân đầu mối đã nhiều cầu khoảng 8,5 triệu mấy khối sang rau,
cùng với lượng tường con và sản xuất trong nước, 1 công được bảo đảm đến hết tháng 3, thật tế,
dựng biến xuất bộ tại trúc đông từ cuối tháng 2 đã tắt lộ mạnh đến phía trường năng lượng tháng 4,
trước tình hình này, bộ công thương đã xây giữa nguyên phía bản điều hành theo từng dài đoạn,
đồng thời của hợp với các bộ ngày trên khai giải pháp ở định phía trường.
Đến này, 1 công sang rau sản lượng khai thác tăng 3 mình con chăm, bảo đảm nguyên địa ở trọng xuất đến hết tháng 3,
tựa nhảm mấy lọng rau rau rau của lối với nhảm mấy lọng hòa rau nghe sơn,
được bảo đảm nguyên địa ở sản xuất tới hết tháng 3, 1 công trong nước tiếp tục được cùng cố khi các nhảm mấy lọng rau rui trình hòa độ ở địa,
bảo đảm nguyên địa ở sản xuất, bộ công thương cũng thà mưu chính phủ và hành các quy định về điều hành giả.
Bộ hợp để xuất sự giụng cuối mình ở năng rau thời gian tới,
các giải pháp như đà giảng hóa ngủng công, tháng dự trữ thương mại phát triển như lửa xin học và ứng dụng công nghệ trong phản chí sẽ tất tục được xin khai,
nhằm bảo đảm ăn định nâng lượng cú ra.